MALE SPEAKER: We're
really pleased today
to have Theodore Gray from
my alma mater, University
of Illinois, here today.
Theo is the author of
"The Elements-- A Visual
Explanation," which some
of you probably have.
He has about 1 million
copies in print,
and he also is the co-founder
of Wolfram Research, 1987.
Are you working on
WolframAlpha now or--
THEODORE GRAY:
Yeah, not anymore.
MALE SPEAKER: Not anymore.
So today he's got
an exciting new book
I can't wait to read on
"Molecules-- the Elements
and the Architecture
of Everything."
So please welcome Theodore Gray.
[APPLAUSE]
THEODORE GRAY: Hello.
So I put up the cat slide.
I added this after my first
talk on this book tour
because right before
the very first talk
that I gave on this
book tour, this kid
came up with his phone.
And he was very
excited to show me
a picture of this cat, because
this is the cat that he's
named after me, because
he's such a big fan.
It's like, well, I guess
it's downhill from here.
[LAUGHTER]
Anyway, so actually, how many
of you have my "Elements" book
or have seen it?
So that's quite a few--
maybe just a very quick recap
of how I ended up in
this line of work.
There's this book,
"Uncle Tungsten."
So if you like my book, you'll
definitely like this one.
It's a great book.
It's by Oliver Sacks.
And he talks about
this periodic table
that he used to visit in
the Science Museum in London
when he was a kid.
And when I was reading
this, I thought
he meant a table that was in
the shape of the periodic table.
And I thought that was
just the coolest idea ever.
And then I read along
a little further
and discovered that actually,
no, it's just a wall display,
same as everybody else's, and it
was kind of confusingly worded.
But that gave me
the idea that there
ought to be a periodic table.
So I ended up building
this periodic table,
and for various
reasons that don't
make a whole lot of sense--
[CELLPHONE VIBRATING]
What?
Somebody's calling me.
That's not going to work.
So because of some
technicalities
in how I built it, it ended up
with each of the little element
tiles that are engraved with
the information being loose,
with a little
compartment underneath.
And because of that, I thought
I could get some elements
and put them into
those compartments
and collect elements.
And then I discovered
eBay, which was just
kind of coming into its
own around that time--
this was like 2002 or so.
And the whole
enterprise has been
a series of slippery slopes
and maybe a little bit
poor decision-making
or something
because it just kind
of got out of hand.
And I've since actually had
to add two more display cases,
so far, to hold the
various elements .
Then Oliver Sacks heard
about this and the fact
that it was his fault
that I built this table.
And so he came to visit
it, and that was cool.
And then I got this thing
called the Ig Nobel Prize,
which is awarded for
achievements that cannot
or should not be replicated,
which I think it was pretty
much the only honor for which
a periodic table table is
actually eligible.
And so I made a crappy website.
And then I got a call
from "Popular Science"
who said would you
like to write a column?
So I ended up spending
literally 10 years
writing a column for
"Popular Science."
And I'll tell you in a little
bit why I stopped doing that.
So that was like
one page every month
about some random topic
in chemistry or science
or something like that.
It turned into two
books-- "Mad Science" is
the first five years. "Mad
Science 2" was the second five
years.
I improved my website.
I got periodictable.com,
which is a beautiful URL.
Anyway, so when I started
collecting these elements,
I realized if I don't
take a picture of each one
and write a little
description of it,
I'm going to forget
what they are.
There's just no way that
I'm going to remember 50--
let alone 500 or 3,000,
currently-- different element
samples.
So I started photographing them,
and I kind of got into that
and started doing
it a little better.
And eventually, I ended up with
a set of photographs like this.
And I thought, well,
I should make a poster
because periodic tables
are kind of boring.
And so I published this poster
right before Christmas 2005
or 2006, something like that.
And that did pretty well.
People liked it.
And then at some
point, I thought, well,
I guess I have enough.
I could probably write a
little bit about each element.
And I've got several different
samples about each element,
so I should make a
book, because I'm not
making any money on the website.
I was making like
$300 or $400 a month
on Google Ads,
which is very nice.
Thank you, Google.
But it's not that
exciting in terms
of putting more work into it.
Although I understand
Simon has friends
who make a good bit more
than that on similar science
sorts of themed websites.
But nevertheless, I thought
a book would be good,
because a book you can put
it in paper and can sell it.
And so this now has, as of this
summer, about a million copies
in print in 23 languages,
which is very nice.
What people who look at the
print book don't realize
is that at some point,
rather than just
taking a picture
of each thing, I
started putting each
thing on a turntable
and doing a VR rotation of
it, where we do a photograph
from every angle all
the way around, so
that I could actually start
doing things like this.
But the problem was
that there wasn't really
any platform on which it seemed
realistic to use this imagery.
You can't print it,
because it's paper.
And you can't really sell it
as desktop computer software.
It just didn't make
a whole lot of sense.
But fortunately, Steve Jobs
had this semi-annual descent
from a higher plane to
hand the world a thing
that they didn't know that
they needed it, but couldn't
live without.
And just a few months after we
came out with the print book,
the iPad was announced.
And I thought, wow, that
is exactly what I need.
I could make an ebook in
which all the objects-- so
in the actual ebook, you
spin them with your finger.
They're not just continuously
animated like that.
You just take each
one and spin it.
And through various reasons
to do with Wolfram Research
more so than science
writing, we actually
had a prototype iPad for
the two-month interval
between the announcement and
the ship date of the iPad, which
was a deep dark
secret at the time.
But it was fun, because
it meant we could actually
do a pretty good job of
developing this software
and releasing it as an
iPad app simultaneously
with the launch of the iPad.
And that's done really
well, because it's
very good for Apple, and
it's in their TV commercials.
We're going to skip the Japanese
elements song because-- we're
just going to, because some
of you may have heard it
and some of you may not.
Either way, we don't
need to play it again.
So that led to me
starting a company
called Touchpress, which is an
iPad app publishing company.
Sorry, no Android at the moment.
And we've published
20 or so apps.
The reason I stopped doing
my "Popular Science" column
is because we did this thing
called "Disney Animated," which
was iPad App of
the Year last year.
And through a series
of what I consider
a very poor decision-making
process on the part of Disney,
they decided that I should
be the author of the ebook
component of that app, as well
as the designer of the thing.
And when I was
growing up, I wasn't
allowed to watch Disney movies,
because my parents considered
them kind of lowbrow.
And so I really knew absolutely
nothing about Disney.
So I had to spend a year
indoctrinating myself
with everything Disney,
and it was kind of fun.
I got to talk to
all these people
and develop the
zeal of the convert,
because I'm new to all this,
and it's all so amazing.
And so we made
this app about it.
And that ended in me
basically blowing off
"Popular Science" for so
long that they eventually
decided I'm not a reliable
columnist anymore.
And now I don't write
that column anymore.
But as a trade-off,
we got iPad App
of the Year, which was cool.
So I spent several years
being kind of distracted,
making essentially
other people's apps.
And I decided a
little over a year ago
that I'm done with that.
I'm going to go back and write
the second in the trilogy
that I had intended to do
from the very beginning
with "Elements"-- elements,
molecules, reactions.
There's a fourth in the trilogy,
which has become necessary
because "Molecules"
doesn't cover
biological macromolecules.
So it will actually be a
four-part trilogy eventually.
So yeah, so I started
on "Molecules,"
and that's what
I'm here for now.
And so now I'm going
to just tell you
some random stories out
of the "Molecules"--
things that I think
are interesting.
We start with this slide, which
actually made more sense when
I was giving this talk
jointly with-- this
is my girlfriend,
Nina Paley-- who
has outstanding
Van de Graaf hair.
It's the best I've ever seen.
So that's an illustration
of static electricity, which
is what holds molecules
together, essentially.
It's the electrostatic
force that
is keeping these things
all knitted together.
And it's also an
illustration of the fact
that I do a lot of
things involving thread.
We have these giant
computerized embroidery machines
and quilting machines.
And the first story
is about thread.
So this is cotton.
This is what you pick if
you're out picking cotton.
And there's little
fibers in there.
All the fibers in a cotton
plant are about an inch long,
and each one has a
tiny seed at the end.
And this is a 6,000 yard
cone of cotton thread.
So 6,000 yards, that's
about 3 and 1/2 miles.
It's actually quite small.
It's the standard commercial
size cone of thread.
And all the fibers in it
are still only an inch long.
They don't glue them
together or anything.
The only thing holding
it together is the twist.
And if you untwist
it very carefully,
you can actually separate the
thread and nothing breaks.
You don't break any
fibers when you take apart
a cotton thread like that,
because they weren't fastened
to each other in
the first place.
And this turns out to
be an excellent analogy
to the way certain polymers
hold each other together.
Polyethylene, for example-- this
is a highly schematic drawing
of polyethylene--
and the connections
down the carbon backbone of a
polyethylene molecule like this
are very, very strong.
But the forces between
the polyethylene molecules
are quite weak.
They're van der Waals
forces, and they're not
really bonded to each other.
And they can actually
slide quite easily.
So if you have a plastic
grocery bag, for example,
you can tear it
apart quite easily.
And for the most part,
you aren't really
breaking those carbon bonds.
You're more like just separating
the molecules from each other.
But if you instead kind
of pull it in such a way
that it stretches
linearly and becomes
kind of more like a fiber,
there's a very specific point
as you're stretching
it-- it deforms.
Then it stretches,
and then it stops.
And it becomes much stronger.
And it's like it cuts into your
finger, and you can't tear it.
And you realize you have to
pull it apart and tear it
the other way because
it's too strong.
That's the point at which
the polyethylene molecules
have lined up with each other
and are now interlocking
in much the way that the fibers
in the cotton thread interlock.
And the strength
that you're feeling
is the strength of the
carbon-carbon bond that
goes down the backbone
of those molecules.
It's actually quite unusual
to be able to directly feel
forces like that, and it
happens because the molecules
are lined up with each other.
And if you take longer
polyethylene chains--
this is ultra high molecular
weight polyethylene--
it's maybe 500,000 carbon units
long versus just a few thousand
in a grocery bag.
And you stretch that
into fibers, you
end up with a fiber
called Dyneema,
which is ordinary polyethylene.
But it's among the
strongest known fibers.
It's stronger than
Kevlar, for example.
Speaking of which,
so Kevlar is strong
not because the
chains are very long.
But because they're actually
kind of sticky in the same way
that cotton fibers are
rough on the surface
and, therefore, kind
of stick to each other.
These benzene rings down the
back of a Kevlar polymer,
they tend to stick
a little stronger.
You can go one
step further, which
is to actually glue
the metaphorical fibers
to each other.
So this is cross-linked
latex rubber-- vulcanized
rubber, as it's known.
You take this natural
rubber, and you treat it
with sulfur and heat.
And you build sulfur bridges
between the polymer molecules.
And when you do that,
you're essentially
turning them into one molecule.
So I have a page
in my book called
"A Shoe-Shaped Molecule,"
because I did my due diligence.
I did some back of the
envelope calculations.
I talked to a couple
of polymer chemists,
and we agreed that
chances are you
could make a defensible argument
that in a vulcanized rubber
shoe like that, there's
at least one sulfur
link from every molecule
to every other one.
And therefore, the whole
thing is one molecule
that's shaped like a shoe.
And I thought that
was kind of funny,
so I called the page "The
Shoe-Shaped Molecule."
And then I gave a talk
about three weeks ago
to a group of chemical
engineers in Seattle.
And I asked them, well,
you're chemical engineers.
What do you think?
Is it one molecule?
And this guy raised
his hand and said,
well, I used to work for Nike.
And we studied vulcanized
rubber shoe soles
and particularly investigated
the question of how much of it
is formed into one molecule
versus how much is still
solubilized.
And he said, no, it's probably
only about 80% one molecule,
and about 20% of it is
not connected to that.
And it's like, Jesus,
what are the chances
that you have a chemical
engineer who specifically
studied the question of
vulcanized rubber shoe soles
and calls you out on that?
I haven't quite decided
yet exactly how I'm
going to fix that
page, but it's going
to have to be fixed somehow.
Anyway, back to the cellulose.
So this is the
cellulose polymer,
and like all simple
polymers, it's
repeating unit over
and over again.
And as some of you may know,
the repeating unit in cellulose
is glucose-- sugar.
And the only reason
it doesn't taste sweet
is because we don't have
any kind of chemical process
in our stomach
that's able to break
the bonds between
the glucose units.
They're connected in a way
that we don't break up.
And so if you eat
grass, it doesn't work.
And if you want to extract the
chemical energy in the sugars
from cellulose, you need a
different chemical process,
which is called cattle-ranching,
where you feed it to cows.
And then you eat the cows
or the milk or whatever.
The energy's there.
You just have to get
it out appropriately.
So this is two forms of sugar.
The one on the left
is 100% glucose.
The one on the right
is 50% glucose,
because the one on
the left is cotton,
and the one on the
right is cotton candy,
which is made of sucrose,
which is glucose plus fructose.
That's a disaccharide.
I just put that in there,
because it's funny.
So cellulose is something
which is made of pure sugar,
but isn't sweet.
There's other things which are
sweet but not made of sugar.
So saccharin's been
around long enough
that there are antique
saccharin artifacts.
This is a saccharin bowl
on top of a sugar bowl.
You notice the saccharin bowl is
much smaller, because you don't
need very much
saccharin, because it's
much more intensely
sweet than sugar.
And there would be these
little tiny pellets--
little tiny
tweezers-- that people
would use to take out
little bits of saccharin
and put them in their coffee.
But there's things
that are much, much
sweeter than saccharin.
So this is 100 pounds
of sugar that I got,
surprisingly expensive.
So it's 170,000 calories,
14,000% of your daily carb
requirements.
And balanced on top, you
can see a tiny little Petri
dish, which we'll zoom in on.
That's 4 and 1/2
grams of neotame,
which is the sweetest
FDA-approved artificial
sweetener.
It's about 300 times
sweeter than NutraSweet,
which it's chemically
derived from.
It's basically NutraSweet plus
a little side chain on it.
10,000 times sweeter
than sugar, depending
on exactly what
you mean by that.
But anyway, so that
4 and 1/2 grams
is roughly equivalent in
sweetness to the sugar.
And this stuff, I
highly recommend it.
You can get like 10 grams
on eBay for about $70,
which is worth it, because it's
all the sweetness you'll ever
need.
And if you ever wonder about
how chemical contamination
or particularly
radioactive contamination
can happen where the
quantities are similarly small,
I got this packet.
It's like a foil
packet, 10 grams.
I opened it up to measure
out the 4 and 1/2 grams
that I calculated I needed.
And within seconds of carefully
and gently opening the packet,
I was tasting sweet in
the back of my throat.
And I didn't puff it or
stir it up or whatever.
I just slowly opened the packet,
and some completely invisible
tiny quantity of this fine
powder-- I had waffed it up,
and I was tasting it.
And the next morning
after taking a shower,
I could lick my beard and taste
sweet on it from-- this stuff
is unbelievably intensely sweet.
And it gets on
everything immediately,
because it's a very fine powder.
And so it's like you'd
be a little bit worried
about chemicals like
that getting out.
I mean, it's like
I'm tasting it,
this chemical that
I was just handling.
And particularly, people worry
about artificial sweeteners,
like should you be eating
aspartame, for example?
Which I do in very
large quantities,
because I drink
nothing but Diet Coke.
And so I did a
little calculation,
like what level of
exposure are you getting?
Say you were to take an
appropriate amount of neotame
and sweeten the cup
of coffee with it,
the equivalent sweetness
that you would typically use.
And what if it were
as toxic as the most
toxic known synthetic compound,
which is VX nerve agent?
And it turns out
you would actually
be several times below
the LD50 of VX nerve
agent in the quantity of
neotame that you used.
So you'd probably survive.
You'd have a pretty high
probability actually
of surviving, even if it were as
poisonous as the most poisonous
known synthetic substance.
And that kind of
colors my attitude
about a number of
chemicals when you
think about just how little
it is that you actually
are using, especially with
artificial sweeteners, which
are very high intensity things.
And then there's also
always the question
of natural versus synthetic.
So two of these are synthetic.
Two of them are natural.
You can tell the
difference, by the way.
The natural
chemicals, very often,
are hugely more complicated.
Like to synthesize
Stevia or mogroside,
that would be a hugely
complicated synthesis
nobody would try.
So we tend to make much
simpler, smaller molecules,
like, for example, saccharin.
So here's a fact you may
not know about Sweet 'N Low.
Saccharin is so sweet that
the amount of saccharin
that you need to put
in a cup of coffee
is impractically
small, like it would
be a few grains of salt amount.
And so the packet is
actually mostly filler.
It's about 6% saccharin
and 94% filler.
You want to guess
what the filler is?
Glucose.
Dextrose-- nutritive dextrose
is what it's listed as,
but that's an exact
synonym for glucose.
And you notice how it
says "zero calorie" on it.
You may wonder how does
it say zero calorie on it
if it's basically pure sugar?
And the answer is because
there's an FDA regulation that
says you can round calories
to the nearest five calories.
If it's less than five,
you can round down.
So it's one gram of glucose.
There's four calories
in one gram of glucose.
So this is the situation.
So I'm slightly diabetic,
you know, borderline.
I shouldn't be eating sugar.
And I think it's just
absolutely outrageous
that this natural
chemical is allowed
to contaminate the pure
clean synthetic that I
was looking for.
I want saccharin.
I don't want sugar.
Sugar's bad for me.
Sugar is unhealthy.
The tiny little bit of saccharin
that's in there, that's great.
Even California no longer has
the saccharin warning on it
that many of you may remember.
And the reason is because they
actually figured out not only
that it doesn't
actually cause cancer,
but why it was mistakenly
thought to cause cancer,
like the mechanism by
which that mistake was made
was thoroughly understood.
So much so, that even
California took it
off that famous list of
chemicals known to California.
But that un-banning
of saccharin is still
rippling throughout the world.
So this is a seemingly identical
packet of Sweet 'N Low,
but this one's from Canada.
And if you look carefully,
it's sweetened with cyclamate
because saccharin is
still banned in Canada.
Cyclamate is still
banned in the US
for the same sort
of residual reason.
And so we have mutually
illegal Sweet 'N Lows
between the US and Canada.
They're both almost pure sugar.
And in Europe, by the
way, which is usually
much stricter about this,
both saccharin and cyclamate
are legal now.
And almost all these
sorts of sweeteners
are a mixture of the two,
because they taste better
together.
And we'll get there.
Oh, there we are.
There's the Canadian
Sweet 'N Low.
I was using the wrong slide.
You can tell it's Canadian
because of the French.
And if you look on
the back, you should
be able to read the cyclamate
ingredient there somewhere--
sodium cyclamate.
Anyway, so at this
point, lest I sound
like a shill for the chemical
industry, I want to show you
a synthetic chemical
I don't think
should be used as an
artificial sweetener.
So this was most recently
used on a large scale
as an artificial sweetener
by the Romans, who knew it
under its alchemical
name of "sugar of lead."
The modern name is lead
acetate, and it's no longer
used as a sweetener
because it's lead.
And there is no
quantity of lead that
is known not to be dangerous.
There's no lower safety
limit known for lead.
It's really bad.
You shouldn't be eating it.
What's most
surprising, actually,
is that this brand and
a couple other brands
of progressive hair dyes
for men use lead acetate
as their pigment.
And when your hair is being
darkened by this stuff,
it's the accumulation
of lead in your hair
that's causing that darkening.
And the fact that
that's legal is bizarre.
And it's an antique regulatory
leftover, banned in Europe,
and being phased
out here, I think.
Because even the
companies that make
this stuff have realized
that this is probably
not a great idea.
And if you read
the FDA exemption
for why lead acetate is allowed,
it's like, if you wear gloves,
and if you engage in a
great many elaborate safety
precautions, it's
hypothetically possible
not to poison yourself
with the stuff.
But realistically, not a good
idea, and definitely not as an
artificial sweetener.
But that's not because
it's a synthetic chemical.
It's because it contains
lead, and lead is toxic.
So this is another
example I like.
This is black licorice, right?
So black licorice, which
is not to be confused
with red licorice, which
is not licorice at all.
The real stuff-- the
principal flavor component
is glycyrrhizin, which is toxic.
It's quite significantly
toxic, to the point
where if you-- I mean, it's
like several hundred grams a day
over a period of many months.
You would build up a
dose of glycyrrhizin
which is at a level where
it's known to be toxic.
It's kidney toxicity,
I think, primarily.
If it were a synthetic chemical
artificial food ingredient,
there's absolutely no way it
would ever have been permitted
or it would have
been banned long ago.
But because it's a
natural plant product,
it's completely unregulated.
There's no limitation
on the amount
of the stuff that
can be in licorice.
And there's actually
companies that
advertise particularly strong
licorice for aficionados
of licorice.
And they're advertising the
degree-- the high concentration
of toxic glycyrrhizin
that's in there.
And that's fine, because it's
a plant extract and who cares?
Must be good for you.
Another one of my
favorite plant extracts--
I happen to have a couple
of friends who had recently
been to Peru, just
by coincidence,
when I was working on this book.
And they brought me back these.
So one of them is coca
leaf tea, commonly
available in tourist traps.
And the thing on the
left is dried coca leaf,
which you probably know that
the principle alkaloid component
is cocaine, which is a
natural plant product.
And it has its
pluses and minuses.
I mean, as a topical
anesthetic, it
was absolutely revolutionary.
It was the first dental
anesthetic that really worked,
and it continues to be used to
this day in medical practice
as a topical anesthetic,
very effective.
Of course, it also
has other uses.
Although amusingly,
one of the problems
with being a drug
addict is that you have,
generally speaking, poor
medical care, and particularly,
poor dental care.
So you get a lot of toothaches.
And doctors won't prescribe
pain medication for you
because you're a drug addict,
and they won't do that.
So it's widely known
to drug addicts
that rubbing powder
cocaine on their gums
is really effective as a
treatment for toothache.
And in fact, it's
better pain management
than most people get
from their doctor,
because the doctor
is not legally
allowed to prescribe
cocaine for toothaches.
And it's by far the best
thing you could actually
have for a toothache.
But then there's the
downside that-- so this
is a video of cooking
cocaine hydrochloride, which
is how you get it
straight out of the plant
into freebase cocaine, otherwise
known as crack cocaine.
And I don't think we're going
to watch the entire process,
but it's basically baking
soda and a lighter.
And you turn this
thing which you
can't smoke into
something you can smoke.
And so here on the left,
that's a rock of crack cocaine.
The thing on the right
is a rock of heroin.
And the reason I put this
slide up with these two
next to each other
is because it's
a very good example of public
policy debates about chemicals.
People have many
opinions about drugs.
Is crack better for you
than heroin or vice versa?
Or of all the different
things that you
can debate about the
issues to do with drug use,
the fact that the
one on the left
is a natural plant extract,
whereas the one on the right
is a synthetic chemical
never comes up.
And why would it?
Because it's just
completely irrelevant.
Who cares?
When you're talking about
substances like this,
it makes absolutely
no difference
whether it's natural
or synthetic.
And yet, very often, that is
precisely the only content
of public debate about the
relative merits of one chemical
over another or whether
a certain chemical
should be allowed.
This came up last
year quite prominently
in the case of
azodicarbonamide, which
is a chemical that's used
in commercial bread baking,
or at least used to be.
And there was sort of
a big to-do about this.
And Subway announced
that they were
going to stop using
this in their dough.
And when it's heated, it
turns into semicarbazide,
and there's some evidence
that that might be harmful.
Regulators in Europe are
looking at it in a sensible way
to see whether it ought
to be permitted or not.
But the public debate
in the US was entirely
based on people repeating
over and over again
that this chemical is used
to make rubber yoga mats.
And why should
you use a chemical
that's used to make rubber
yoga mats in your bread?
Like, this is terrible,
and we should ban this.
And Subway essentially
backed down
and said, OK, we're
going to stop using it.
And this is a dumb way
of debating chemicals.
And I hope it doesn't go any
farther, because I happen
to really like lye bread--
these little lye rolls.
And the way you make lye
bread, it fundamentally
involves the use of
lye, hence the name.
Lye is another name
for sodium hydroxide.
It's drain opener.
If you're a crack
dealer, and you
have a problem
with somebody, lye
is what you use to
dispose of the bodies.
So it's a very,
very nasty chemical.
It's tremendously caustic.
It's a drain opener.
Should we be using drain
opener to make bread?
Yes, absolutely.
There's no reason not to use
drain opener to make bread,
because the fact that you
can use a chemical for one
thing or another has
nothing to do with it.
The question is,
what is the chemical?
Is it good for you?
Is it harmful?
How is it being used?
What's the dose?
All kinds of questions that
essentially didn't come up
at all in the debate
about azodicarbonamide.
And the fact is that
actually everybody
loves chemicals, no
matter what they say.
For example, if you
like asparagus--
I happen to be particularly
fond of asparagus.
If you like asparagus,
these are the chemicals
that you particularly
like the taste of.
If you like some other
food, I can give you
another list of the chemicals
that you like the taste of.
Many of these chemicals
are insecticides.
They're pesticides.
They're fungicides.
They're antibacterial agents.
None of them are
put there by us.
They're put there by the
plant, because plants
have this problem
that they're immobile.
They can't move.
Their only defense
is chemical warfare
against being eaten
by various things.
And so plants are actually
very active participants
in the enterprise of
generating toxic chemicals.
Actually, here's some
more random chemicals.
You probably can't
read it there.
This happens to list the colors
that are made by the plant
to color themselves in this
way in each of these cases.
And so plants spend a lot of
time making toxic chemicals.
Here, for example,
these are the four most
toxic known compounds.
The top three are
all-natural products.
The VX nerve agent
is number four.
It's about 2,000
times less toxic
than number one,
which is botulinum.
Number two is
maitotoxin, which is
made by a type of
marine plankton.
Number three is the
poison dart frog poison.
These are all-natural products.
Plants are really good at that.
And it's disconcerting,
disheartening,
and sort of dysfunctional
to talk about chemicals
so exclusively as, is it
artificial and therefore bad?
Or is it natural
and therefore good?
You get it wrong in
two different ways.
So this is another project that
we worked on in Touchpress--
a book about the whole
DNA exoneration enterprise
that's now-- and has
been for some time
now-- discovering these
tremendous injustices that
happened decades ago,
people who were locked up.
And one lesson from that
is the power of DNA.
It turns out DNA is
really, really powerful,
not just for solving crimes, but
for investigating many things.
For example-- and the reason
I put the reference up there
is because every
time I say this,
I have trouble believing it.
But go read the study.
I read the whole thing.
It's very thoroughly done.
It's a totally legit study.
What they did was
they investigated
herbal supplements.
They went out
around the country.
They bought 40 or 50
different national brands
of herbal supplements, and
they did DNA fingerprinting
on the plant material that
was in those supplements.
And then they compared-- they
went to botanical greenhouses
and had experts
identify-- they made
a library of DNA fingerprints
of herbs of known provenance,
so they could very
authoritatively
determine what's in those
supplements and what's not.
And so not surprising, like 60%
or 65%, something like that,
were found to contain
plant material that
was not listed on the labels.
Nobody's perfect.
That doesn't seem
so shocking to me.
What's more surprising
is over 30% of them
contained none of any of
the listed ingredients
at all-- none of any of
the listed ingredients.
So to represent this in my
book-- because I did actually
want to go out and buy an
herbal supplement pill,
and there was no point.
I just raked up some
leaves in the backyard
and chopped them up and
put them in a pill, which
is to say I did
exactly the same thing
as 30% of the manufacturers
of these supplements.
And the point is
that if you blindly
believe claims of all-natural,
wholesome, you know,
we're a small family
farm, you may actually
be dealing with a
rapacious corporation based
in New Jersey, which
is ripping you off.
And it's not really
useful to apply skepticism
because it's Monsanto,
but not because it's
this friendly company.
One ought to use
truth and mechanisms
for actually finding the truth
to determine these things,
rather than what essentially
amounts to prejudice,
I think I'll skip this
particular example.
Right, yeah, so let's
skip that example
and go right on to the funniest
thing I know about vanilla,
which is my last little example.
And then we can have
little demos here.
So, as you may know,
there's two kinds of vanilla
you can get in the store.
There's natural vanilla, and
there's artificial vanilla.
And it turns out these
are chemically identical.
It's the same vanilla, and
it's the same molecule.
One is derived
from vanilla beans,
and it's very
expensive because you
have to grow the vanilla beans.
They actually, apparently,
have to be pollinated
by hand in a
rainforest plantation.
And then they have
to be fermented,
and it's quite expensive
to make natural vanilla.
Synthetic vanilla, I
got a kilogram on eBay
for like $20 or something.
It's a trivial chemical
to synthesize, dirt cheap.
And this, of course, means
there's a tremendous temptation
for companies to adulterate
and to sell artificial vanilla
calling it natural, because
there's huge profit to be made.
And there's no
chemical test that
can determine the difference.
It's impossible to
apply any chemical test.
But you can tell the difference.
And the way you do it
is based on carbon-14.
As you may know, the atmosphere
is full of carbon-14--
well, tiny amounts,
but anyway-- it's
incorporated by plants into
their cells when they grow.
And it then very slowly
decays over tens of thousands
of years.
Natural vanilla is
made from plants
that grew quite recently.
Artificial vanilla is made
from petroleum feedstocks,
which is also plants.
But the plants grew
a very long time ago.
And so the carbon-14
is completely decayed.
So the way you tell is that
natural vanilla is radioactive,
whereas synthetic
vanilla is not.
And this is actually
how this is detected
in the commercial trade.
If the carbon-14 date of your
vanilla is too old, it's fake.
In other words, if it's not
radioactive enough, it's fake.
Which I just think is, I
don't know, for some reason,
I think that's very funny--
[LAUGHTER]
--and a good example of the
use of science to find truth.
Anyway, so these
are all my books,
which you should all buy.
Then I want to do two things.
I want to show you
a preview-- now
it's, I guess it's a release
candidate beta version
something on there in between
of the "Molecules" app.
And then I have a couple
of demonstrations.
OK, yeah, so this
is the-- and like
I say, unfortunately,
no Android,
but maybe you guys can
talk me into it someday.
The iPad version of "Molecules",
so it has things in it.
You can spin them.
Let's see If we go to
here, unlike on "Elements,"
it has a larger number of
what I refer to as "still life
video," which is kind of an
aesthetic I've been developing.
So these are little things
that move when you touch them.
They're not really videos,
but they are video,
and they kind of
exist on the page.
And they're meant to
illustrate, in this case,
the different viscosity between
longer and shorter hydrocarbon
chains, respectively.
But the thing that's really
interesting in this app
is something that you
really have not seen before.
I'm trying to find the
right place to-- yeah,
so here's a good one.
So when you see these
diagrams of molecules.
I mean, you've seen
them everywhere, right?
These are all lies.
Molecules are not flat
things like that on paper.
And if you've seen 3D
renderings of molecules
or plastic 3D models of
molecules, those are lies, too.
Because-- I mean they're closer.
Molecules are
three-dimensional things,
but they aren't
rigid things at all.
This is actually what
molecules really look like.
They're, generally
speaking, very flexible,
floppy things that are
in constant motion.
They're always vibrating.
And so what we have
in the "Molecules" app
is this high-end piece of
molecular dynamic simulation
software that's normally
a supercomputer thing,
but we're doing it
with small molecules.
And it's doing quantum
mechanics guided
simulation, legitimate molecular
dynamic simulation of what
these molecules
are actually like
with multi-touch interface.
So you can pick
up separate parts
of the molecule simultaneously
and kind of stretch it out.
I actually managed to-- if you
go to that maitotoxin, which
is an amazing multifused
ring structure-- we'll
get it in here somewhere.
So yeah, if you zoom
in, it's just one ring
after another, all different
sizes, the kind of thing
that only biology can
synthesize molecules like this.
And I managed to
tie it in a knot.
It takes about a minute
or two to do this,
but you can actually
pick this thing up
and very slowly-- the
simulation's a little slow--
but you can actually drag this
thing out and tie a knot in it.
Anyway, I think this is going
to be quite interesting when
a large number of people get
to actually see and experience
what molecules are like
as living, moving things.
But it's not out yet.
It will be out next week
or maybe the week after.
I think the week after.
OK.
And now, we have just
a couple of demos.
We'll leave this one for last,
in case it's the last demo.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
So the first one
is along the lines
of telling real from fake.
So I don't do the kind of
really spectacular science demos
that people sometimes do.
So I try to have some
kind of relevance to them.
And this one is
practical advice on how
to tell real silk
from fake silk.
It turns out that fake silk
is actually incredibly good
these days.
And even experts can't
really reliably tell
just by feeling it
whether it's real or not.
Because there's enough variation
in what real silk is like.
And the imitations
are good enough
that you need a better way.
And obviously, you can do
chemical analyses or whatever.
But there's a much
simpler way, which
is to simply burn a bit of it.
And apparently, if
you're a silk buyer
and you're evaluating
something, that's how you do it,
is you take a lighter along.
And you pull a little
thread out of the garment,
and you light it.
And so I read about
this, and I was
thinking it sounds pretty clear,
but how does it really look?
And so I'll give you now
a practical demonstration
of how you tell what
it actually looks like.
And thank you, Simon,
for this fine torch.
So you burn it,
and if it's silk--
you see how it kind of melts?
It actually pulls
back a little bit,
but then it always puts
itself out-- eventually.
And this is the point
where we'll all find out.
And it leaves a char behind.
There's a black
char, and it smells
of burning hair--
terrible smell.
Synthetic.
So this is, I believe
this is nylon.
It feels really nice.
It's a beautiful rope.
Now when you burn
this-- and this will
be true of any synthetic
imitation silk-- first of all,
it melts much more.
And when it does eventually
catch fire-- yeah,
that is absolutely
diagnostic of fake silk, when
you have the dripping flaming
balls of death falling down.
That's not silk.
But it's also much
more attractive
really in a darkened room.
That's kind of fun.
Oh, oh, and right,
and you can hear.
I don't know if
you can hear that.
Let me see.
Anyway, this is
really a fun demo
to do when the kids are not
there, because they learn.
OK, now we can hopefully
get this to go out.
AUDIENCE: Spray some
hair spray on it.
THEODORE GRAY: Yeah,
that will probably work.
OK.
So there's a whole
section in the book,
and in particular on
the app, it's good.
There's a whole section of lots
of different fibers burning,
and it's quite
attractive, the ways
in which different
types of fibers burn.
Some of them burn
very differently.
Cotton balls burn in
a very beautiful way.
Kevlar doesn't burn at all.
And then, of course, there's the
whole natural versus synthetic.
But one of the more
surprising things that burns
is actually steel wool.
You might not think of
steel or iron as flammable.
And normally it isn't,
but only because normally,
when you have some of it,
it's a big chunk of it
with a substantial volume
versus surface area.
But if you have fine
steel wool like this,
it has very little volume
and a lot of surface area.
And it turns out it's actually--
and we should at this point
turn off the lights,
if that's possible.
Does anybody know how
to turn off the-- oh,
there's a bunch of light
switches over here.
AUDIENCE: Right there.
THEODORE GRAY: Ah, can you?
AUDIENCE: Over there.
THEODORE GRAY: There we go.
Perfect, OK.
Oh, great.
Yeah, so it turns out
that steel wool actually
burns very nicely, and
it's quite attractive
when it works right.
I just light it
here, and then you
get this lovely kind of little
worms of fire coming up.
And you notice that it's
different from most kinds
of fire that you see, because
the fire is happening right
on the surface of the metal.
Normally, when you have wood
burning or something like that,
the fire is above the wood.
And that's because
what's actually happening
is that the wood
is volatilizing,
and there's flammable
gases that are going.
Well, it's the gas
above that's really
doing most of the burning.
But here, nothing
volatilizes, and there's
no smoke, other than a tiny bit
from residual oil on the steel
wool.
Because what's
happening is the iron
is being converted in
place into iron oxide.
And, actually, what's
happening, this is rusting.
This is just high-speed rust.
And rusting is a very
exothermic process.
And it when happens fast
enough, things get hot,
and then we call it fire.
But really, it's just rusting.
And it puts itself out, because
there's not much left to do.
We'll just let that burn out.
You can turn the-- I guess
you could leave them off.
I don't know.
So one of the
chapters in the book
is called "I Hate
That Molecule," which
I hate that title.
I think that's a really
stupid title for the chapter.
What I really wanted to call
it is "Molecules That Piss
People Off," but
they wouldn't let
me do that, because
children and all.
And so that's a
chapter about molecules
which just cause people to be
angry about something or other
and cause there to
be hate in the world.
And the number
one molecule there
is thimerosal, because of the
whole anti-vaccination deal,
which whatever side
of that you're on--
and I hope you're on
pro-vaccination side--
but either way, people
get really angry.
People call each other
murderers and whatever.
Another class of
compounds that's on there
is chlorofluorocarbons.
So that debate is
kind of over now.
And actually, I was just
reading just after the book went
to press that for
the first time,
the ozone hole is
getting better again now.
It's like there's actually
been some progress
in atmospheric science.
But there was a time when
there was tremendous discord
about that and people
calling each other names.
And one of the
arguments that was made
is that chlorofluorocarbons,
particularly in aerosol cans,
are really good because
they're not flammable.
And the alternatives
are, generally speaking,
pretty flammable.
And that argument
eventually was won over
in the survival of the
species side of the camp.
And so now we have
aerosol cans that
are much more exciting
than they used
to be because their propellants
are now more flammable.
And so I brought you
three examples of that.
Two hair sprays--
and this, I don't
get to do this demo when there's
children present, because even
I draw the line at
teaching kids how
to make flame throwers with
their mom's hair spray.
AUDIENCE: What is
the propellant?
THEODORE GRAY: Well,
it depends, so that's
why I get different brands.
We can see what
it is in this one.
Let's see, this is SD alcohol,
which is not a propellant,
and hydrofluorocarbon 152a.
Usually there's a-- where is it?
No, so that one is-- usually
there's an ether in there.
I didn't actually read
these ingredients before.
Aminomethyl propanol
could be the propellant.
Where is it?
Anyway, yeah, usually
there's like a methyl ethyl--
is it methyl ethyl ketone?
What is it?
I forget.
I don't know.
There's various things.
It's like they try to make it
as non-flammable as they can,
but without the
chlorofluorocarbon,
you're kind of limited.
So we were going
to aim that away.
So this one's actually
fairly tame, I think.
I forget which one it is.
So if you've ever seen
the James Bond movie,
it actually does work.
And then this one is a
slightly different combination.
You can tell how volatile
some of the components
are by how far back the flame
reaches towards the can.
You want to go with brands where
it doesn't reach the nozzle.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, so--
Actually, the valves
in these aerosol cans
are deep inside the metal,
and so there's not actually
that much opportunity for
the entire can to explode.
So it turns out that if you want
this actually to work really
well, you need to pick something
which not only has a flammable
propellant, but was actually
intended to be flammable,
namely starter fluid.
[LAUGHTER]
This works really well.
AUDIENCE: Ooh!
Woohoo!
THEODORE GRAY: So
I guess you got
a router up there or something.
[LAUGHTER]
And we want to stay away
from the sprinkler system.
It's highly recommended
as a home demonstration
of something.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, so now we
find out how good
the fire detection
system in here is.
I don't know if you
could feel the heat,
but it's actually
surprisingly hot.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
THEODORE GRAY: So OK,
well, there you go.
Thank you very much.
That's my demonstration.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So I work on Chrome,
and I'm a little bit biased
on people building native
apps versus for iOS or Android
or something versus the web.
And obviously, you got
started a few years ago
when the web couldn't do as
many things as it can do now.
I was wondering if
you could talk nerdily
a little bit about why
you just have an iOS
app versus an Android app,
and whether or not you've
looked at being able to do
some of this stuff on the web,
because your apps are amazing.
THEODORE GRAY: That's
a good question.
And I mean, so the "Elements"
app and the "Molecules" app,
with the exception of the
molecular dynamic simulation,
is-- you could do that
as an HTML5 thing.
I mean, being able to spin--
I think five years ago when
we did it, it was
probably not really going
to be super smooth
as a web thing.
It probably could be
done as a web thing.
But many of the apps that
we do have a lot more stuff
that you can't really do as
a web app sort of a thing.
I don't know how you
exactly describe it,
but you need your fingers on
the hardware a little more.
You need performance.
You need access to
bits of the hardware
that you can't necessarily get
to through a web interface.
And we're in the business
of publishing apps
to make money on the
sales of the apps, which
is a really tough
business to be in.
I think it's gotten worse
and worse over time.
So the "Elements" app
just-- we've sold,
I think, 360,000 copies,
something like that, at $14
a copy.
And that's very
unusual for apps.
It's like apps don't cost $14.
And if they do, they don't
sell in those sort of numbers.
And that's our
best-selling app to date.
That's our first app.
It's the one that got
the company started.
We've had a few other apps
that have been successful
at those price points.
"Disney Animated" has done
reasonably well at $10 a copy.
We make these super
premium, lush--
they're like the app equivalent
of a coffee table book.
And it's very
difficult to get people
to consider the concept of
paying actual money, let alone
like $10, for an app--
the exact same people
who would not bat an
eye at paying $20 or $30
for a print book or even $10 for
an ebook, just a regular ebook
on their Kindle, with no
pictures or anything, just
plain text.
People are more willing to
spend $10 on a plain text ebook,
than they are on the
same text in an app.
There was a great example
that some book-- not one
of ours-- but a book that
came out simultaneously
in print, as a static ebook, as
an audio book, and as an app.
The app, of course,
included everything
that all the other
versions had--
the full text and the
recording and plus lots
of other interactivity.
And, of course, the app
was by far the cheapest.
The audio book was
the most expensive,
and the ebook was in between.
And that makes no sense.
It's entirely the psychological
environment of the app store.
And that's unfortunately a
place where the Android app
store is even worse
than the iOS app store.
The iOS app store started out,
and particularly for iPad apps,
supporting a
reasonably high price
point for people who wanted to
make money by actually selling
the apps, as opposed
to many people
who make apps who
have completely
different ways of making
money or who are just
going for the viral hit and can
make by with a few cents a user
or something.
And every time we try to think
about doing this for Android--
and it's not that we have
anything against Android.
It's just we have
X amount of money
to put into developing
our next app.
And if we do this for iOS,
we have some expectation
of what we're
going to make back.
We have one platform to target.
Well, all right, two
or three or whatever.
But they're all very
nicely integrated.
They all-- it works.
We look at Android,
it's like first of all,
forget all the
phones, because people
don't use this on phones.
So you're talking
about tablets only.
It's fragmentation.
It's maintenance.
The development costs
are much higher.
And the store is not one that is
conducive to high-priced apps.
And so we always just
say no, you know what?
Let's make another iOS app.
And I wish it weren't so.
And I wish we could do something
that would be cross-platform
as a web thing, but
when you're doing
synchronized audio,
complex interactivity
with multiple streams
of audio and things
and video-- our
apps are very big.
They're like a gigabyte
or more sometimes.
It's like there's only one
platform where that really
make sense.
And that's, unfortunately,
right now iOS.
And I think it's like the
days are numbered where we're
going to keep doing this,
because the returns are
actually not improving,
despite the number of devices,
because the app store
environment is deteriorating.
AUDIENCE: What inspired
you to get into chemistry
and stay in chemistry?
THEODORE GRAY: Well, actually I
was never really in chemistry.
So I have a bachelor's
degree in chemistry,
and then I dropped out
of graduate school to go
and co-found Wolfram Research
with Stephen Wolfram, which
is the makers of Mathematica,
and ultimately, WolframAlpha.
And so I spent the
last-- I mean, that
was 1987-- and up until
a couple of years ago,
that was kind of my job.
And this whole periodic
table book-writing stuff
was just a hobby.
Since then, I've
now transitioned
into Touch Press,
our map company,
being my primary occupation.
And since then, decided, OK, no,
I'm just going to be a writer
and do this, because
this is much more
interesting than working
on other people's projects.
But as far as why
chemistry, I don't know.
I like the names.
I think organic chemical
naming systems are fascinating.
That was my original reason for
studying organic chemistry--
not a good basis
for a career choice.
And then the reason I decided
to get out of chemistry
was because I realized that if
I became a professional chemist,
particularly an
academic chemist,
I wouldn't get to
do any chemistry.
But you know, I like blowing
stuff up and mixing things.
And you can't do that if you're
a chemist, because you spend
all your time writing
grant proposals.
And being a science writer, like
for "Popular Science" column,
every month, for 10 years,
I got to blow something up.
They'd send a photographer down.
I had a big shop.
And we would do something
involving chemicals--
build transparent
rocket engines.
It's all this stuff
that you don't
get to do if you're
actually a chemist.
So my interest was primarily
nurtured and expanded
by not actually being a chemist
in a professional sense,
but getting to do
all the stuff that
is the most fun
and the most useful
in terms of communicating
chemistry to the public.
I actually got an award from
the American Chemical Society
called the Grady Stack Award
for Communication of Chemistry
to the Public, which I
think of as the "We Found
a Journalist Who Doesn't Hate
Us" award, which is hard.
It's hard for them, and they
don't have a lot of choice,
as evidenced by the fact
that they gave it to me.
AUDIENCE: With all the
content that you have,
have you ever considered
creating a MOOC
to open chemistry to the masses?
THEODORE GRAY: Funny
you should ask.
Yes, I have thought about it.
And I've also thought
about how much
I enjoy not being a creator
of stuff that actually
gets officially used in schools.
Right?
Because as soon as you do that,
there are so many restrictions,
and there's so
much you can't do.
Like my books will
find themselves
in the library of
a grade school,
if no parent has noticed.
And it's like the more
enlightened parents get it
for their kids, but it would
never, ever pass as a textbook.
And I wouldn't want to have
to take everything out of it.
Actually, in the case
of the "Molecules" book,
I admit, OK, we sold so
many copies of "Elements"
to the Scholastic book
fairs, where they go around
to schools, and they have
these displays-- lots
of copies every year.
And so my publisher
was very eager
that they should do the
same thing with "Molecules."
And so they ran it by them.
And there was this
woman who reminds
me Dolores Umbridge from the
"Harry Potter" series, who
went through it line by line.
And we cut out-- you
know, there was some stuff
that even I have to admit
after the fact was perhaps
a bit off-color and maybe
not really belonging there.
There was a marijuana
bud that was full-page.
It was gorgeous.
I mean it was just
unbelievably beautiful.
And you can talk about
the fact that that's
a pesticide to the plant.
The THC is a pesticide
that the plant makes.
But we took it out,
because it's just
like, you don't
really need that.
And we made the
heroin rock smaller.
And it was gorgeous, too.
It's a beautiful,
beautiful rock of heroin
that I had to flush down the
toilet, because you really
can't hang on to
that kind of thing.
[LAUGHTER]
Where was I going with this?
I don't know.
Yeah, so right, actually
being a textbook author
isn't very appealing
because you don't
get to do that kind of stuff.
However, there's value in it
and watch this space perhaps.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
Let's all thank Theo for coming
here and giving a super fun
talk.
[APPLAUSE]